from the guy who brought you the
extended edition of Justice League the
extended edition of Watchmen and the
extended edition of Sucker Punch comes
the soon to be extended Rebel
moon now don't get me wrong I'm not one
of those channels who hates every single
film that comes out for clicks but every
once in a while a film comes along that
infuriates me from its bloated budget
non-existent character development and
razor thin plot you know it's bad when
Disney passes on it seriously have you
seen what they've been coming out with
lately eat it up hope okay 3 2 1 not
only am I going to pinpoint why I think
Rebel moon is a disaster but I'm going
to go one step further and show how a
few simple changes could have
transformed Rebel Moon into something
truly special I'll be using some
comparisons to Star Wars A New Hope so
there will be spoilers for that but
seriously if you've seen Rebel Moon and
not a New Hope may God have mercy on
your soul so get out you're definitely
not trademark by Disney lightsabers it's
time to cut this thing apart by far the
biggest glaring problem with Rebel Moon
are its thinly developed characters
specifically its protagonist Kora AKA
arthus when she's not smelling the Earth
she's farming their Rich soils of velt a
small farming community on the outskirts
of the mother World basically Rebel
Moon's version of the Empire and it's
pretty insane the amount of similarities
Rebel has with Star Wars especially
within its first hour we have a
protagonist who leaves their home on a
small farm to Adventure to a Cantina
only to be accosted by the locals and
meet a who will help them to where they
need to go seriously it's cut and past
Star Wars except there's a big
difference I care about Luke I don't
care about Kora let me tell you why one
of the greatest elements of a story is
character Arc Luke starts off as this
poor naive Farm Boy with dreams of
getting off planet and being an ace
pilot just like his dad remember he
doesn't know who his dad is just yet we
care about Luke not because he loses his
aunt and uncle but because we know what
it's like to to have a dream and not be
given a chance to achieve it we
empathize with him for God's sakes one
of the most iconic scenes in all of Star
Wars maybe even all of film is Luke
staring at Twin's double Sunset yearning
for a life beyond contrast this with
Kora she doesn't want to leave in fact
I'm not sure what she wants at all we
see her plow the fields talk about
marrying a dude she just kind of does
stuff Kora as we'll find out is also an
accomplished Soldier a master who's able
to chop down many men on her own so she
doesn't have to undergo training like
Luke Kora is like if a New Hope were to
follow Obi-Wan instead of Luke and
although we all love Obi-Wan it would
make for a very different film Obi-Wan
is what we call a static character in a
new hope he's not meant to change rather
act as a changing force for our
protagonist but Kora doesn't change nor
does she change others she exists merely
as a vessel to get us to the next fight
scene so how do we fix this two ways
first we could make someone else the
protagonist now hear me out imagine how
different the story would be if Gunner
were the main character he's a farm boy
who's never been off Planet but dreams
of one day doing so he's probably never
held a gun in his life the Empire comes
in and he watches as they kill his
family and is threatened that more will
die should he and the village be unable
to produce their precious grains the
only way to save them is to team up with
a mysterious woman named Kora and unlike
the film where we're given this
extensive flashbacks of what kora's life
was cor's backstory here remains a
mystery just like Obi-Wan's like imagine
if Obi-Wan were to go into this huge
10-minute flashback about how he fought
Vader on Mustafar it's completely
unnecessary the second option is to keep
Kora as the main character but set up a
more established character Arc something
where we can see she'll grow as a
character remember that she was a
soldier of the mother world she was
taught to show no softness so let's see
that let's see her as this cold-hearted
soldier who doesn't want to get involved
with anyone or anything I was taught
that love is
weakness I don't know how that will ever
change instead of telling me show me
this isn't a spoiler but blueeye Samurai
has this great scene where the
protagonist could give this starving
woman and child some money for food but
doesn't this brief scene tells us a
whole heck of a lot about this character
in only a few seconds now let's try this
with Kora imagine how heart-wrenching
this scene would be if Sam pleads for
cor to help her but she does not nothing
perhaps she even walks away it will only
be when Kora herself gets caught by
these men that she'll have to intercede
Sam is saved but only as a byproduct of
Kora having to save her own ass this
leaves room for Kora to change over the
course of the movie and as she
establishes relationships with the other
crew members the climax would include a
moment where she must make a similar
decision a Redemption if you will will
she fight and risk her life for someone
other than herself proving that she's
changed or do nothing nothing and if you
thought our protagonist had no character
development well don't even get me
started on these secondary characters
the second act of the film is basically
Kora and gunar going around collecting a
group of ragtag soldiers to join them in
their cause but so little is really
known about them that we never really
get a chance to just hang out with them
and discover their Dynamics with one
another one of the things I loved about
James gun's Guardians of the Galaxy is
that all the characters feel distinct
from one another and interact in organic
and fun ways we never get that scene
here where they're all just sitting
around having a laugh talking to
one another show me the camaraderie of
this team and make me root for them how
does Nemesis talk to Tar what happens
when tar takes a swig of one of titus'
drinks instead we get a 10-minute long
hippogriff taming scene which is
completely useless having less fleshed
out secondary characters also means the
film's big betrayal doesn't hit as hard
Kai is our Han Solo type character but
unlike Han he doesn't have an arc in A
New Hope Han is only helping for money
he decides not to help in the battle
against the Death Star but surprises
Everyone by showing up proving there's
more to him than just dollars and cents
see even the secondary characters in
Star Wars have an arc now imagine how
much more gut-wrenching Kai's betrayal
would have been if he weren't this
one-dimensional character who only wants
money what if Kai had no other choice
than to turn her in even having
developed feelings for Kora as the story
progressed perhaps he owed the Empire or
risked losing his family children Etc
the Betrayal then become much more
personal and also a heart-wrenching
decision for Kai himself making his
eventual death all the more tragic
making character decisions personal is a
great way at elevating the stakes of not
only our protagonists but villains as
well Rebel Moon's main Baddie is an
admiral named attakus Noble he's
hellbent on finding this Rogue band of
rebels so that he can prove himself to
his master bisari but the film doesn't
even scratch the surface of the Dynamics
between these two even though it's set
it up which makes it all the more
frustrating remember that Kora was
adopted by basarios and raised as his
daughter becoming his Protege Noble
seems to be this new Protege calling
bisaria Master Noble's goal shouldn't be
for fame the right songs of my Feats of
Courage but to prove to bisar that he is
the superior student he wants to earn
bisari Us's love that's way more
compelling and feels more personal than
simply getting Fame for turning these
guys in now on to the plot which often
times finds itself stretched thin and
includes scenes that don't Advance the
story whatsoever one of the metrics
writers use to determine if a scene is
needed or not is whether you can take
that scene out and see if the story
still works this 2-hour film is littered
with scenes that aren't needed such as
the scene between Sam and the robot
Jimmy it's a nice scene but doesn't
really change the overall plot now some
of you might argue well this is setting
something up for part two again I look
at Star Wars there are no scenes like
this in A New Hope and that's a movie in
a nine-part Anthology I really don't
know how Netflix and Snyder can justify
this getting an Extended Cut when the
film should really only be an hour and a
half Max the plot also seems to drive
the story rather than the characters for
example the plot requires cor and gunar
to get a ship off planet in pop Skai who
even though they tell him they have
little to no money agrees to risk his
life and join them anyway the plot LED
that decision because it was required of
it not the car
I found the same thing happened with
Daran blood axe's decision to join Kora
they're going to take on this giant
dreadn basically as suicide mission and
he's like hell yeah I'm in but there are
smaller nitpicky things that felt a
little far-fetched to me like why does
this super Advanced spaceship need this
particular community's grain so bad can
it not go home to another planet the
ship can warp through space but can't
make enough food I also didn't quite get
why cor went after these particular crew
members I get that Nemesis here is a
great swordsman but how how is she going
to help take down an army of millions
how is General Titus going to be of help
when they don't have an Army in fact
their whole plan in Saving velt and
taking down Noble doesn't account for
the fact that this is just going to piss
off the Empire more and puts velt into
even more Jeopardy than it was before I
also found the CGI Pirates of the
Caribbean looking creature to be
distracting I get that it's cool to have
alien creatures but if the CGI is going
to distract me either make them
practical or just make them human and
some of the set pieces make it look real
obvious the actors are in front of a
green screen I could also tell that
Netflix really held back the blood and
gore to give this a PG-13 rating
especially in this first fight scene now
the Extended Cut is supposedly going to
be rated R well I think Rebel moon is a
failure the thing that upsets me the
most is that it didn't have to be most
of my criticisms of this film are
completely story- based and could be
fixed before going into production I
hate this new trend of director's cuts
that I have to watch in addition to the
original in order to get the story the
way the director intended how about
releasing a film the way it's supposed
to be released it's all getting so
tiresome but now I turn it over to you
what did you think of Rebel moon are my
criticisms fair or are we looking at the
dawn of a new Sci-Fi epic that will
stand the test of time let me know in
the comments below thanks for watching
be sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at bigstory YT
until next time remember Daddy loves you
very
much